a warning that mark white's report does
contain images of the injured attacker
this is supposed to be a nation in
lockdown
but neither the covet health emergency
nor the terror threat warning
could keep these people from coming into
the center of nice
to pay their respects at the notre dame
basilica
among them silva isandra who knew one of
the victims
church warden vincent locke she's
devastated
it's really sad it is i'm christian but
that's got nothing to do with this
why have they done this this is the
attack suspect
tunisian migrant brahim aousaui pictured
here being treated by medics after he
was shot
he's still critically injured in
hospital
the attack comes against the backdrop of
a deepening crisis in this country
a clash between secular france and the
cultural sensitivities
of many of its 6 million muslims
i've come here to nissa's northern
quarter at a sprawling collection of
tower blocks
home to many of the city's muslim
immigrants
has invited me to his 12th floor
apartment
to join his family celebrating the birth
of the prophet muhammad
saeed came to france almost six decades
ago from morocco
like the vast majority of french muslims
he utterly condemns the terrorist attack
here
it's more than sadness disgust also
anger at what happened
anger also because we're not doing what
we need to we're letting people
run around who shouldn't be here but
it's not just the extremists who side
blames for france's current predicament
the french president has he says become
increasingly hostile
announcements by the government's
announcements because it's them
provoking this now
this is coming from the head of state
told me it's becoming increasingly
difficult
for more moderate voices in the
community to exert any influence or
control
over a growing number of younger muslim
immigrants
we're becoming increasingly extreme mark
white
sky news nice